[Applause]  this incredible glacier located in  alaska is a popular tourist destination  but the best way to see it is from the  inside  mendenhall glacier is a 12 mile long  glacier in the mendenhall valley in  alaska's tongus national forest  the ice caves are the glacier's surreal  interior  access to see these icy walls are only  available to the truly adventurous  to see the ice caves requires a kayak  trip and ice climb over the glacier and  once you're inside the faith that the  melting walls around you won't give away  but this natural wonder is under threat  the glacier has been retreating  incredibly quickly in recent years due  to warmer temperatures and rising sea  levels  it has receded by almost two miles since  1958  but what remains is an utterly  breathtaking fantasy land  [Music]  you